Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment publisher of the batman
arkham series tt games Lego series and
nether realm Entertainment's Mortal
Kombat and injustice fighting games has
pledged to support nintendo's new NX
console I'm Lucy and welcome to your I
got your back bro gamespot news updates
speaking to VentureBeat the publishers
president david Hadad discussed
microsoft's project scorpio and
Nintendo's NX saying that we be support
of these platforms is unquestionable we
have great relationships with all the
console platforms we believe we play a
role in each of them what I saw with the
announcements that were made at e3 2016
I'm fairly bullish about the console
cycle about gamers spending time on them
and finding great content about
publishers being able to find returns on
increasing investments in that space
we're constantly deciding how to
navigate that but supporting them is not
a question for us you may remember that
Warner Brothers was a big supporter of
the wii u releasing titles such as
batman arkham city armored edition early
in the platform's life and continuing
its support with games such as injustice
gods among us and scribblenauts unmasked
a DC Comics adventure it maintained its
support of the Wii U as sales declined
while many other publishers reduce their
focus on Nintendo's consoles Nintendo
has confirmed that its next gaming
platform codenamed NX will be launching
globally in March 2017 followed by
Microsoft's new console project Scorpio
which will release later that year so
what do you make a wee B's pledge of
support are you going to be picking up
an NX or a Scorpio let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games for more
on all the brand new consoles make sure
you keep it gamespot
you